zero is a perfectly good number and you
ignore it at your peril the problem is
it's a dangerous number and a lot of
things can go horribly wrong with zero
because it is a slightly more unusual
nuanced number you have to be more
careful with how you handle it and so
there are some things that you can't do
with it so you can't divide something by
zero
and you can't have things like zero to
the power of zero
and i get asked about these all the time
people are constantly why can't i divide
by zero i want to divide by zero isn't
it just infinity blah blah blah and so i
thought i would i would do two things
first of all i'm going to show you why
no you cannot divide by zero it's not
just infinity it's a bit more
complicated than that and then i'm also
going to look at why you can't have zero
to the power of zero
okay so this is something that we've
been asked a lot at number five well you
may know that something like uh
multiplication is just glorified adding
really if you wanna do five times ten
you just add on five plus five plus five
plus five ten times
division is just glorified subtraction
so if i want to take a number like oh 20
and then divide it by four
i just keep subtracting four so you
divide take away four take away four
take away four you do that five times
and that number five that's your answer
20 divided by four is equal to five so
it's just glorified subtraction that's
really what it is now if i divide by
zero
then that means i'm subtracting zero
over and over so 20 divided by zero
means i take away zero
i've got twenty
and then i take away zero again i've
still got 20 i'd take away 0 and a 0.
and that would go on forever you would
never get very far doing something like
that keep taking away 0. so
20 divided by 0
that's infinity isn't it surely surely
it's infinity and that's what i expect
people to think right surely only a nerd
would tell you differently that's when
you cut them out telling them
differently so first of all everyone
goes why why can't you just say that
something divided by zero so let's say
i'm going to do a function i'm going to
have the function of 1 over x we don't
say something is equal
to infinity okay so infinity is not a
number and it can't be treated like a
number okay it's an idea so we can't say
divided by 0 equals infinity we can no
more say that then we can say 1 divided
by 0 is equal to blue all right but if i
am naughty right and i do this 1 divided
by 0 is equal to infinity you would get
just as equally 2 divided by 0 equal to
infinity and obviously you get the
problem here that
1 seems to be equal to 2. obviously
that's nonsense and that's why we don't
so for very good reason we don't say
it's equal to infinity you're going to
get nonsense like 1 equals 2. but they
say what if you take a limit what if you
just take the limit as x gets really
close to 0 doesn't this equal
infinity
and and so you would say that actually
dividing by zero you could therefore
conclude that one divided by zero equals
infinity and i'm going to show you why
you can't do that so if you imagine your
number line here so this is the number
line
i'm going to put 0 right there so
there's 0 in the middle and out here
this might be 1 and then so on all the
way up and as you go along
this here i'm going to draw on this axis
going up
this here is my uh one over
x i'm going to have one over x on that
and over here when it's one this would
be about one there when you come back to
let's say about a half
this is going to be a bit bigger it
seems like it's going to be twice as big
by the time you get down to about a
quarter that's going to be twice as big
again if you come and as you get closer
and closer this does it does i
absolutely agree this gets bigger and
bigger this goes racing off
and it does tend to infinity this is
absolutely correct but this only works
if you're approaching zero from the
positive numbers if you're coming in
from the right on your number line if
you come in from the left it's
completely different so if you start
over here at negative one
then your value is actually uh down here
at one
if you then go to negative a half it's
down here at negative
two and as you get closer and closer the
value goes racing off in this direction
in fact it goes racing down
to negative
infinity so yes if you approach zero
from one direction you get infinity but
if you come in a different way to
exactly the same place
you get well you can't get much more
different than negative infinity and
people will yell at me if i say it's
infinitely different from positive
infinity blah blah maybe maybe this line
goes all the way around and wraps around
the entire universe and then comes back
up here but as far as i'm concerned
if you come in from one direction you
get one answer if you come in from the
other direction you get a different
answer you're going to the same place
there is no one limit of as you get
closer and closer to dividing by zero
there's more than one limit with
completely different answers and that's
why we say it's undefined mathematically
what we would say is we say i want blue
this time sorry if you approach the
limit as x 0 from the positive direction
equals positive infinity and then
separately down here
the limit as x approaches 0 from the
negative direction of 1 over x equals
negative infinity and these are
different they equal different things we
simply cannot
just assume that one over zero equals
infinity if you go to zero from this
direction
it's going off to plus infinity and if
you go to zero from this direction
it goes off to minus infinity two
different answers when i type one
divided by zero into my calculator or my
computer
it can't do it it can't handle it
what's it trying to do though what can
it not do what happens in those circuits
what did it try and fail to do or has
the calculator been taught
that's a very good question
is it attempting to do something
and then it's not getting an answer has
it just been wrote taught don't divide
by zero i honestly don't know i suspect
it's just been taught
that
if someone hits divided by zero say
error or what it might do is actually
try to get to that answer by an
iterative process which then finds
exploding in one direction or the other
and so it's got some kind of built-in
cap or some kind of safety switch which
goes off to say this calculation is
getting out of control call it off here
just say maths error but i i imagine it
might even vary from device to device
but it'll be one of the two
the other thing that people get very
annoyed about is when you've got zero
to the power of zero and the reason they
get annoyed about this is when you've
got anything
anything at all to the power of zero you
always say it equals one
and when you've got zero to the power of
anything you always say it equals zero
so what happens when these collide and
people to be honest
argue different ways depending on what
they need more often than not people
argue for zero to the zero equals 1 in
my experience although the video i did
on 345 for number file people in the
comments argued that 0 to the 0 should
be 0 which is of course equally insane
and i'm going to show you why you can't
have this and this is absolutely lovely
because when you start with your number
line here so this is this is the normal
number line there's 0 in the middle this
time you're going to look at the limit
as x approaches 0 but this time our
function is x to the power of x right
and we're going to slide it in and in
fact we have to do it from both
directions we have to come in from the
positive direction and as we know we
have to come in
the limit as x approaches 0 from the
negative direction of x to the x and
we'll see what we get and obviously if
they're different then things are going
horribly wrong so if i draw in my
y-axis here this is where i'm going to
be graphing x to the x as you get closer
in and to be honest the path we follow
is irrelevant but what happens is as you
come in from one side you hit one
as you come in from the other side you
hit one in fact these have exactly the
same answer they both give you one and
so you say well if it doesn't matter
which side we're coming in from if if we
can come in along the number line this
way into the middle or we can come along
the number line this way into the middle
and both cases the function has the same
limit surely we can just call it one
but it's slightly more complicated
because this is only
the real number line i'm not going to go
into this but the real number line is
very boring because it's one dimensional
you can go backwards and forwards on
your numbers you've also got the complex
numbers and for that you need to put in
the imaginary so i'm going to put in
this is my imaginary axis
and so now you've got like this entire
surface of numbers and you've got real
in one direction imaginary and the other
and any single point on there is part of
the complex plane in fact now there are
loads of different ways to come in
towards the origin and you can approach
it from anywhere on the complex plane
and then these approaches you get
different limits you don't get one
anymore it starts to fall apart once you
go to the complex plane and so this is
why
even though on the surface of it
it might look like the limit should be
one it doesn't work once you go to
complex numbers and that's why
mathematicians still get very emotional
when you try to say that 0 to the 0 has
a value in fact it is still
undefined because the limits vary
how about
something like x divided by y all right
so i'm going to draw here's x and here's
y
all right if i think about x divided by
if i think about x divided by y
there's this is going to be fine
except here this is called the origin
it's the point zero zero x is equal to
zero and y is equal to zero so at this
point we have something that is zero
divided by zero
that doesn't sound like good news at all
what is that is that zero is it infinity
what is it
in fact it can be any answer you want it
to be depending on the angle you come
from i'll show you what i mean now this
line
is y equals x right this line
now if i travel along that line
then this thing here
x over y
well i say it's y equals x this is
actually x divided by x now
which is one
so this is one everything on this line
is one
so it i it would be okay if i'm only
traveling along that line i would be
quite happy to say that that
is a one as well everything else is so
i'm going to say yeah that is that's
called a removable singularity that's
its proper name
if i travel along this direction this is
the line
y equals minus x
if i do that so y equals minus x in that
case you get x divided by y
y
is equal to minus x
so this is minus one
everything on this line is minus one
now let's try this i'm going to travel
along the x-axis
x-axis in other words this is y equals 0
that's what the x-axis is so y equals 0.
if i do that
then i get
x divided by y
i've said y equals zero
so this is x divided by zero oh dear
well we know that this is a problem
but
it's going to be something like and i'm
going to be naughty
you know it's it's going off to infinity
plus infinity minus infinity but it's
it's something like that
if i go along this direction
which is the y-axis
here
x equals zero down here
if i do this same thing
right x equals zero so i'm going to say
zero x is equal to zero divide by y
that's zero divided by y everything on
this line is equal to zero
so i would be justified to say well
that point is the only problem take it
out and call it zero so and it does
depend on which angle you approach from
in fact i can make any number i've made
minus one plus one infinity and zero
and you depending on which angle you
come at
you can you can make any number you want
out of that so that
zero divided by zero
is this property called undefined
frankly we could make it to be anything
we want it to be depending on the angle
we come at it from
when you have
it's all to do with the angle
that the match takes as being sort of